i could dribble i could shoot
i'm more than a post player baby speed
is picked up there it is oh little hesi
oh another cross and the finish bang
[Music]
welcome in yet again to underrated the
only show that allows your favorite
professional athletes to improve their
video game ratings you see who's behind
me baddest in the land when it comes to
the wnba liz cambage and she does not
like what she's getting from nba 2k
we're fixing that today
and now i'm gonna bother her
hey liz
we're gonna go to our 2k expert davis to
see how she stacks up on the sticks
the game of basketball has evolved a lot
centers are no longer just getting
rebounds and dumping it off to their
point guards they need to be able to run
the floor and i know for a fact liz can
do that her athleticism is extremely
underrated on 2k now i understand it's
probably because she doesn't necessarily
in game take off with the ball that much
but we know she's athletic she literally
holds the all-time record for wnba
points in a game
[Applause]
don't try to intimidate me
um
your
wnba 2k character yeah you're ball
handling
do you care to guess what the rating is
is it in the 30s that's bad isn't it
59. oh that's not that bad but i believe
i'm a person dribbling while running is
a 35. i mean i told you i'm a caged
animal like i can yell that if i get the
rebound and i just
go to the first phrase
yes i am fast with the ball i just don't
get to show y'all
you think you're better than a 59
definitely
i have the guy that can make it happen
word where he at ronnie oh
[Music]
wow is that yourself oh yeah wow that's
how you get a 90-day rating
cancel this i'm not doing a show unless
i have a shirt with my face on it did
you hear what we were talking about a
little bit
59 ball handling she believes that she
is quote a caged animal yes and that
today she'd like to show you that she's
much more than a 59. that's why i'm here
this is the opportunity to get that
rating up let's go okay and in order to
make this happen we've brought in four
prehistoric beasts
are you ready to test your ball handling
i love a challenge okay ronnie bring
your shirt let's go check this out i'll
bring i'll bring minnie ronnie
a center dribbling the ball down the
court might be a surprising sight to
some
not unlike the surprisingly great rates
at state farm
all right so liz we want game speed game
speed no lolla gagging
oops [ __ ] you got beat he's trying to
come with you are you ready i just go
for it three
two
one
go
ah
hey hey
[Music]
with the scoop
bam
look to be honest we're here to improve
the nba 2k rating yeah that's a big deal
yeah
so i think one more time
do it for the little people out there
now do it for my big gods baby
[Music]
in three two
one
oh speed is picked up there it is
a little heavy across
oh another cross and there's no doubt
so much better the behind the back get
it on
[Applause]
yeah and it melted away just like that
yeah
did you see enough
to go up from a 59 ball handling i was
impressed
i think minimum we gotta be at a 62.
minimum i appreciate that yeah you're
officially in the 60s now i was just
upset that there was a five in front the
entire time
we already know liz is one of the taller
players in the league and the fact that
she can shoot that efficiently as well
catches you on bronze is not doing it
for her alright no defender is
disrupting her jump shot
[Applause]
[Music]
your badge for catch and shoot is a bra
yeah
we want to get it to a silver yeah how
does the bronze make you feel no but
catches shoot specifically
well once again it's like an area of my
game i don't really get to show because
i'm always in the post but like i'm cash
baby that's what the show is about
though when drake says we're like i'm
lizzy
cash baby make her rain that's me that
about you yeah you didn't know that
really yeah you're in a drake song
she doesn't even need this show
now i need to get my ratings up baby
underrated that's what we're doing it's
catch and shoot guys all right so here's
how this is gonna work
ronnie is gonna feed you the pass yeah
we're gonna start off in the beginning
yes they're gonna be clean passes okay
we're bringing a defender that's gonna
get right in your face then
defender
plus bad ronnie passes okay but we're
looking here for how quickly that's
right she catches it and releases it
right
are you ready in three
two one
okay defender having impact early on
[Music]
that one's in that one's in this is
where the flow happens she's really now
the flow is happening she's really
brushing that shot
don't keep that close do keep that flow
still keeping
i don't know it's looking good to me
there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the defender
impacting you
no no the defender is now angry
time okay okay okay okay
but now defender plus bad ronnie passes
ah are you ready
yes sir
three two one
oh
[Music]
ah
high pass funk defender i pass
oh a dribbler
and knocks it down she's adjusting well
low pass that's a tough spot
oh she got it
it's a lot of ground to cover with the
low pass
yes did you feel proud yeah
talk it out give me these emotions i got
to show the real me i can dribble i can
shoot
i'm more than a post player baby we're
setting the record straight yeah this
isn't just about ratings it's about how
we're perceived by the world and now the
world knows what did you think about her
i was impressed i was impressed it
looked good the defender didn't really
throw off my terrible passes didn't
really throw her off she looked good
okay she was a bronze
yeah i think that needs to be
reconsidered i think
i think we got silver
silver dreams
you're not getting a bruiser no no i
lost all my badges what do you have to
say to ronnie and the 2k fans so lovely
doing business with you thank you
thanks for having me and to all the
people out there there's any other
challenges let's go i'm ready i'm
playing let's let's keep that score
going up and now i get to do my favorite
thing what
ronnie 2k yes
was miss kambesh underrated she was
underrated
that was crazy
thank you wow it feels good to hear and
that's why we do what we do
underrated thanks ronnie you're welcome
i can't wait until i get a shirt with my
face
one day mom one day
[Music]